[Musique]
là il ya une occasion à saisir et à ne
pas laisser échapper
parce que ce dessin est un dessin très
connue très connu et en plus ce qui
concerne directement donc le fondateur
de la toile de jouy et donc c'est assez
naturel qu on essaye de trouver les
moyens financiers pour pouvoir
l'acquérir dans une galerie privée et
elle est on a réussi à obtenir de cette
galerie que plutôt qu'il qui la met en
vente et qu'elle parte on ne sait où qui
nous donne le temps de pouvoir réunir
les sommes nécessaires pour pouvoir
l'acquérir en faveur du musée a lancé
une campagne via une plateforme de de
financement participatif comme on dit
qui s'appelle d'artagnan qui est une
grande plateforme connue en france